hi Bill my name is Cameron and I am a
junior at Liberty Bell High School in
Washington and I was just wondering on
this hypothetical question if if there
was a completely intelligent all-knowing
entity whether it was human or otherwise
uh that if if it existed and it was our
leader if we should be completely
subservient and submit to its governance
be if it really truly had our best
interest you know at heart this super
entity that we should serve I don't know
I see for me there's no evidence of a
super entity with a plan for everybody's
life and this goes way back Charles
Darwin wrote about this speculated about
this and another way to express it if
there is a super entity running things
why is everything so screwed up and the
reason seems to be that humans are all
interacting all trying to get food
shelter and raise their kids and there's
conflict among us it's just the way
humans are and so if there is a super
entity I would like I would prefer that
she or he was just a little more
organized just took care of things a
little better and the thing to be
careful of in my opinion is when people
you meet are sure that they have a super
entity that's telling them what to do
that affects you that is to say when
they tell you you can't do this you
can't do that because the super entity
of mind is telling me that I should tell
you that you can't do that that's when
there's conflict and I presume you're in
Washington state and you know Washington
state is way in the west of North
America a lot of the people that came
from Europe came here to get away from
certain
pidgins which by modern standards where
we see the strife in wars around the
world were pretty tame the religious
expectations were not that onerous yet
they were onerous enough to make people
leave get us don't tell me what to do
kind of thing so I'm open-minded but as
we say you can't prove a negative and by
that I mean if if you say or if someone
says well can you prove that there is no
super entity you can't because whatever
proof you'd offer as that there's no
super entity the other other side would
say well that's just what the super
entity wants you to think super entity
is hiding from you super entity is
making it so you can't find super entity
anyway that's that's arguing in a circle
you'll never be able to resolve that so
whether or not you should serve the
super entity is up to you but I strongly
encourage you to look for evidence of
the super entity before you get caught
up in trying to serve it him or her it's
a fantastic question
you're asking a deep question but for me
understanding of nature in the world
around us and how I should interact with
our fellow humans I get a lot more
satisfying answers from the process of
science than I do from people claiming
to have a super entity that's going to
tell me or us what to do and the
troubling thing in science pretty
quickly you figure out that you can't
figure it all out that there are
unknowns there are things that you just
do not know and for some people that's
really troubling but for people like me
it's empowering because we have a
process the process that we call science
that enables us to learn about nature
and the example that everybody is all
excited about right now everywhere I go
is are there other universes are there
multiverses
universe is beyond our universe and the
big argument for their the existence of
these multi Multi verses is that there
isn't any real good way to exclude them
there's no way to make sure that they
don't exist so maybe they do and that's
cool and exciting and by the way you are
alive when people discover dark matter
apparently there's five times as much
dark matter as there is regular matter
and do you know why nobody knows why but
in your lifetime maybe discoveries will
be made that will tell us about dark
matter and dark energy in my
grandfather's lifetime there was no such
thing as relativity people didn't know
about relativity yet if you have a
smartphone and it tells you which side
of the street you're on that information
comes from spacecraft in orbit around
the earth that have to be adjusted for
both special relativity the speed of the
spacecraft relative to the Earth's
surface and in general relativity the
effect that the Earth's gravity has on
clocks on time the speed of time as I
like to say so who knows what
discoveries will be made soon and I
would I the thing I'm saying here is
that science carries with it this
uncertainty this we don't know at all we
accept that we don't know at all but we
have a process for trying to find out
and that to me is elegant and beautiful
carry on
you